hi everyone it's Jen I'm your ad is
snack time who doesn't like to snack I
love my snacks and I have a snack in
every day I've got a huge variety of
snacks here today and all of these
snacks are under 100 calories so who say
we can't have a low calorie snack yeah
it's full of nutrients and it's really
healthy whether your lunch I've got a
snack for you if you're an ice-cream
lover just like me I've got a snack for
you as well if you're really busy and
you have a hectic schedule and you like
to snack on the go I've got that as well
if you like the creamy texture of yogurt
I've got a snack for you as well if you
are someone who likes crunch crunch
crunch I've got that for you and I can't
forget chocolate lovers
I've got the ultimate snack for you as
well at the end of this video I want you
to leave your comment and let me know
which is your favorite snack and you can
even share me your own recipe so let's
start let's start with the first recipe
if you have a sweet tooth
you're constantly busy and you barely
have time to eat and you like to snack
on the go then this recipe is for you
I'm going to show you how to make a know
peanut chocolate raisin snack bar once
your business you can store this into an
airtight container and it will last you
up to one week so it's
really convenient and easy for busy
people and people who like to snack on
the go the ingredients you'll need are
30 gram of path wheat cereal 67.5 gram
of oats 50 gram of raisins finely
chopped or you can choose other dried
fruits 150 gram of honey or maple syrup
have a teaspoon of vanilla extract and
50 gram of dark chocolate chips or
finely chopped dark chocolate so the
first step is to add a pop with your
oatmeal and your chopped raisins into a
bowl and I'll just gently hit your honey
with a splash of vanilla don't cook it
just warm it up once your honey is
heated just pour over your dry mixture
okay
just mess it up and make sure that is
all well coated the next step is to add
in your chocolate chips but before you
do that allow it to cool down for five
minutes to avoid your chocolate chips
from melting in the meantime you can
pre-heat your oven to 300 degrees
Fahrenheit and that's about 150 in
Celsius add your chocolate chips when
your mixture is calmed down just fold it
in and mix it up once that's done
transfer it into a baking tray I've only
used 3/4 of my beging true because this
big bacon tree once it's all nicely
pressed down all we're going to do now
is to put it into the oven and bake it
for 30 minutes after 35 minutes remove
it from the oven and you should be
golden brown let it chill for 1 hour
before slicing them into bars so this is
my snack on the go for those of you who
are really busy or you can even make it
and bring it to school or college as
your snack this one bar only contains
89.5 calories but it's full of nutrient
and you will give you the energy to
study to work and its really good for
those of you with hectic schedule so try
it out for those of you who likes to
crunch basically you like the sound of
the fruits or vegetable that you crunch
I would suggest that pick your favorite
vegetable mine is carrots I love carrots
I can just eat carrots on its own
without anything
so I've got character and pick your
favorite tip my favorite tip is the hot
salsa dip firstly because I like spicy
food and secondly it's because each 30
gram of this tip only contains 10
calories so choose your dips and do with
the food label because sometimes dips
can be really high in calories and so
what I have here is about 100 gram of
carrot sticks and about 60 grams of hot
salsa dip and this whole thing only
contains 61 calories I've got it in my
snack box so what I can do is just close
it up bring it out to work or just store
it in the fridge and have it the next
day it's that simple and you will love
the sound of it when you're crunching
and what's better than having lots and
lots of vegetables because that is you
two a day for those of you who likes to
snack on fruits or you like the creamy
texture of yogurt and you like to find a
lot of fruity yoga pots I would suggest
that you actually make your own fruity
yogurt pot that's because most of the
yoga pauses that we buy from the
supermarket are filled with artificial
sugar and it's very high in sugar
instead if you were to make your own you
can really top it up with lots of fresh
fruits and you can choose a better yoga
option as well on top of that you can
add your extra sweetness from your
natural honey
so why you'll need is about 100 grams of
low fat Greek yogurt or just look at
plain yogurt
about one handful of your favorite
fruits I've chosen blueberries and
strawberries here which is about 70 gram
and just half a teaspoon of honey just
for the extra sweetness so I'm going to
add about one teaspoon of honey into my
yogurt just for the sweet flavor and all
I'm doing is just mixing my fresh fruits
into the yogurt so instead of getting a
little bit of flavor from the fruit
while you're getting is lots of fresh
fruits and you're getting the natural
sweetness from the fruits and this is
low in calories as well this is only 98
calories plus you're saving lots of
money so try to make your own yoga pot
instead of buying from the supermarket
ice cream lover
that's me I'm going to show you how to
make this frozen yogurt ice cream which
only contains 54 calories so this is
totally guilt free and it's totally made
of natural ingredients whenever I'm
craving for an ice cream
I would always treat myself to one of
these sticks the ingredients you'll need
six of these fruity yoga ice creams are
225 gram of low fat plain yogurt or
Greek yogurt one peach which is about
100 gram of peach sliced one medium
sized banana which is also about 100
gram of sliced banana and one tablespoon
of hot HS for the extra sweet taste
there is only one step to this recipe
all you need to do is to mix all your
ingredients into a smoothie blender and
now all you'll need to do is to blend
this until all the mixture is nice and
smooth and it will give you like a thick
smoothie so you should have like a thick
mixture and all you'll need to do now is
to pour it into six little popsicle mold
and I've got this from Ikea in the UK
one of this set is about 2 pounds I
believe in America's four dollars from
Ikea you can get it anywhere in the
world so just pour it into six of them
and now all you need to do is to place
this in the freezer for a day and you
can enjoy ice cream the next day there
you have it a low-calorie low-fat frozen
yogurt ice cream which is totally queue
free so if you do have any fruit that is
going off instead of throwing it away
slice it up blend it up and make your
own frozen yogurt ice cream with your
own favorite fruits try it out and let
me know what you think my next snack
idea is for munching if you're someone
who likes to munch constantly and you
like too much a lot of peanuts or even
dry fruits almond nuts I would suggest
that you try my garlic roasted chickpeas
if you're looking for lower calories
alternative try chickpeas instead of
nuts nuts are healthy and chickpeas are
healthy as well adding lots of protein
but they are much lower in calories this
amount of chickpeas which I'm about to
do only contain 92 calories whereas this
amount of nuts will contain about 170 to
180 calories so the ingredients you'll
need are half a can of drained every
chickpeas I've got mine from a can so
that's about 120 gram 1 TSP of olive oil
and about half a teaspoon of garlic
powder for flavor if you like more
garlic you can always add more garlic
the first step is to pre-heat your oven
to 180 degrees Celsius or 350 degrees
Fahrenheit so I've got my chickpeas what
you'll need to do is just lay it out
onto a baking tray
okay and just add your one teaspoon of
olive oil
okay drizzle all over it and just give
it a good mix make sure it's all nice
and covered now for the garlic hint and
flavor for those of you who love garlic
add half a teaspoon of garlic powder if
you really like garlic you can always
add more okay and just mix it up make
sure all the chickpeas are covered so
what we want to do now is to spread it
out and put it into the oven for 30 to
40 minutes so that it's nicely roasted
so that's my garlic roasted chickpeas
they are much lower in calories in
comparison to nuts
this one container is one serving and
it's only 92 calories I know you can get
them in stalls but the one is
supermarkets are usually filled with
salt therefore I would encourage that
you roast lots of chickpeas stored up
into little containers one container one
serving and have them wherever you feel
like munching because then you can
control your portion size and control
your calories intake
for those of you who like savory snacks
savory snacks can be high in calories my
suggestion is for you to go for one
crackers two slices of ham and also a
really light medium soft cheese spread
my favorite is garlic add herbs and one
teaspoon of this only contains about
tangram which is about 15 calories so
all you need to do is grab a cracker
spread your 1 teaspoon of soft cheese on
top of it if you can't choose a light
option and just top it up with two
slices of ham it is really quick and
it's really easy if you're feeling
peckish but you don't want something too
heavy you can try this it will be up for
a good period of time do you like
chocolate
if yes this next recipe is for you I'm
going to show you how to make my banana
lollipop it's really simple it's coated
with chocolate and you will absolutely
love it
and it's really pretty as well if you
ever go to a friend's place for a party
you can always make this snack for all
your friends the ingredients you'll need
are two medium sized bananas which is
about 200 grams 75 gram of dark
chocolate and about 1 tbsp of shredded
coconut so the first step is to slice
each banana into three parts this will
make you six servings then what you want
to do is to grab some really colorful
straws and just to poke through the
bananas or you can even use a stick if
you want to then
step is just to melt the dark chocolate
once the dark chocolate is melted it
just coats each banana with dark
chocolate and sprinkle a good amount of
coconut on it do that for all six sticks
and once it's done place them in the
fridge and let them chill for one hour
check it out and it's ready to be eaten
there you have it my banana lollies each
stick contains about 100 calories the
coconut on it it's great for your
immunity it's really delicious
so do consume it in moderation for those
of you who are looking to increase your
protein intake it's so simple snack on
the whole hard-boiled egg this helpful
egg contains 78 calories and it's
providing you with 6 grams of protein
you know boy 2 to 3 eggs you can keep
them overnight put in your purse and
just have it whenever you feel like
snacking if I'm in a rush I tend to
snack on hard-boiled egg after my
workout it's full of protein and you
need protein for your muscles to recover
so put it in your purse bring it with
you and just snack on handle egg
there you have it these are all a
variety of snacks that I tend to have
depending on my mood and depending on my
activity level my favorite snack is ice
cream I love ice cream and how can you
not have these when it's only 54
calories is this your favorite snack or
is that your favorite snack do let me
know in the comments below don't forget
to friend me on Facebook follow me on
Instagram do check out my website for
all of my videos and also for all of
these recipes and please do like this
video share this video and please
subscribe to my youtube channel for more
fitness and nutritional videos
you